[Musique]
les plus jeunes n'ont que 20 ans les
plus vieux 40
ensemble ils forment la plus grande
compagnie de ballet canadiennes et dans
quelques heures ils seront à l'honneur
sur une des scènes les plus
prestigieuses de moscou
je regarde je peux croire qu'il est
vraiment ici
ici dans ce pays où l'histoire du ballet
s'est écrite un nouveau chapitre se
rédige la danse contemporaine
longtemps boudé en russie s'impose
aujourd'hui au grand public
c'est un rêve j'ai jamais pensé de toute
ma vie que médiateur sur la scène le
danseur étoile et chorégraphe guillaume
côté s'est produit dans les plus grands
théâtres du monde mais présenter son
répertoire moderne à moscou relève d'une
certaine audace mais c'est quand même
quelque chose d'un peu différent s'est
ployé avec la scène qui complètement
ouvert un décor assez bizarre fait que
je sais pas quand le rideau à souffrir
je sais pas quel genre de réaction qu'on
va voir mais
sa chorégraphie l'être et le néant
qui explore la philosophie pourtant
complète de jean paul sartre est d'une
simplicité désarmante
[Musique]
elena en est sorti mollard ya symbiose
de la musique et de la danse dit elle
époustouflant
[Musique]
c'est très profond dans feeling moi je
vais pas les passionnés de voyager
beaucoup c'est un très bel possibilité
de regarder quelque chose de nouveau
si les russes savoure enfin la danse
moderne c'est surtout grâce à la grande
ballerine diana vishneva son festival de
danse contemporaine contexte est
aujourd'hui un incontournable de la
scène artistique monet contenir et elle
dit qu'elle a toujours admiré la
diversité du ballet national canadien
un astronaute baisse de campagne en
avant
et pour la directrice artistique karen
kane être ici ambassadeur de son art en
russie est un honneur 100 et qui va de
même avec des pièces sombres comme immer
jean christophe bette qui ne laisse
personne indifférent
tu vois vraiment que renouvellement de
nouvelle génération qui est vraiment
plus ouvert d'esprit est là je trouve
que la russie c'est un pays qui a évolué
beaucoup dans les dernières années mais
faut être ici vraiment pour le voir
dans une époque de tensions politiques
c'est la diplomatie de l'art qui
l'emportent
la première soirée a été un franc succès
à guichet fermé prochaine à rennes
demain à st peter's et si thammarat
altérer ce courant du canada
moscou